♪
WILL: FRUSTRATION MOUNTING FROM
BUSINESS OWNERS JUST TRYING TO
MAKE END MEET.
>> OUR NEXT GUEST NOSES THIS TOO
WELL HE HAS BEEN FIGHTING WITH
GOVERNOR TO OPEN ACTIVITY PARK
WHILE GIMS HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE
GREEN LIGHT TO OPERATE AT 25%
CAPACITY.
JEDEDIAH: THOMAS GARCIA JOINS US
NOW.
WE ARE CONFUSED.
LOOKING AT THIS AND SAYING IF
GYMS ARE ALLOWED TO REOPEN WHY
IS YOUR ADVENTURE PARK ANY
DIFFERENT?
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO GET ANY
RESPONSE ON THAT?
>> I HAVE BEEN TALKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR’S OFFICE FOR OVER SIX
MONTHS RIGHT NOW I TALKED TO THE
GOVERNOR HERSELF OF THE GOVERNOR
TOLD ME FROM HER OPEN MOUTH THAT
URBAN AIR CAN’T KEEP CAN KEEP TH
SAY BUT CAN’T BECAUSE WE ARE IN
THIS RECREATIONAL CATEGORY BUT
SHE CANNOT OPEN US.
HOW IS THAT RIGHT THAT SHE COMES
AND SAYS THAT HEY, THOMAS, I
THINK YOU CAN KEEP YOUR GUESTS
SAFE BUT I STILL CAN’T OPEN I
STILL CAN’T OPEN YOU THIS IS
WHAT THEY DID IN FLORIDA.
WILL, I KNOW YOU ARE IN FLORIDA
NOW.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DID IN
FLORIDA.
THE GOVERNOR SET PEOPLE TO URBAN
AIR IN FLORIDA BECAUSE THEY GOT
OUR 0 PAGE PLAN OF OUR REOPENING
AND THEY EXAMINED WHAT WE’RE
DOING.
SO, THEY WATCHED US TAKING THE
TEMPERATURE OF OUR GUESTS AS AN
EMPLOYEES AS THEY COME IN.
THEY WATCHED USOUS OUR FOGGING
NONE SPRAY ANTIMICROBIAL ALL OUR
EQUIPMENT.
THEY WATCHED OUR SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
BUT THAT’S HOW YOU TRY TO
MITIGATE CORONAVIRUS IS YOU
EDUCATE BUSINESSES AND FIND
BUSINESSES THAT ARE DOING THE
RIGHT THING AND THEN YOU TRY TO
IMPLEMENT THAT IN OTHER
BUSINESSES.
THAT’S HOW YOU DO IT.
NOT BY RESTRICTING THEM.
WILL: RIGHT.
THOMAS, IT’S HARD TO MAKE SENSE
OF OBVIOUSLY GYMS AS YOU POINTED
OUT.
STRIP CLUBS ARE OPEN IN NEW
MEXICO.
BUT YOU ARE NOT.
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU IS UNIQUE
ABOUT YOUR BUSINESS?
TELL US ABOUT WHAT URBAN AIR IS
AND WHY FOR SOME REASON IT’S
FALLEN ON THE WRONG LINE OF
OPENINGS AND CLOSINGS?
>> SURE.
SO WE ARE IN INDOOR ACTIVE
ENTERTAINMENT VENUE.
AND WE HAVE SUCH THINGS AS
CLIMBING WALLS.
WE HAVE THE ONLY INDOOR
SKYDIVING IN AWFUL NEW MEXICO.
WE HAVE TRAMPOLINES.
WE HAVE A ZIP LINE.
SO WE HAVE A HOT OF THE
EQUIPMENT WHERE OTHER PLACES ARE
OPEN.
SO GYMS ARE OPEN.
ROCK CLIMBING WALL PLACES ARE
OPEN.
MY DAUGHTER GOES TO GYMNASTICS
AND SHE JUMPS ON A TRAMPOLINE
EVERY TIME SHE GOES OVER THERE.
THEY ARE OPEN.
BUT WE, FOR WHATEVER REASON, ARE
NOT OPEN AND IT’S, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE 85 REALLY GOOD EMPLOYEES
THAT WORK FOR US THAT DON’T HAVE
A JOB RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT’S A ACROSS NEW MEXICO.
IT’S NOT JUST ABOUT ME.
IT’S ABOUT A WHOLE LOT OF OTHER
BUSINESSES THAT ARE JUST GETTING
ABSOLUTELY CRUSHED RIGHT NOW.
AND, YOU KNOW, I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH AN EMPLOYEE
YESTERDAY THAT IS LIVING OUT OF
A MOTEL RIGHT NOW.
SO WE’RE ACTUALLY GOING TO HELP
HIM OUT.
WE HAVE ANOTHER LOCATION IN
LITTLETON.
WE ACTUALLY TALKED TO HIM ABOUT
ACTUALLY TEMPORARILY WOULD YOU
MIND GOING TO LITTLE TOP AND
HELPING US THERE?
WE WILL GET YOU SOME FULL TIME
HOUSING OVER YOUR HEAD.
PETE: THOMAS, YOUR BUSINESS IS
TOO UNIQUE FOR A GOVERNMENT
BRUENING CRAZY TO FIGURE IT OUT.
TOO COMPLICATED YOU ARE SHUT
DOWN.
ELEVATE YOUR STORY OF NOTE,
ALSO.
ALL 154 URBAN AIR LOCATIONS IN
AMERICA HAVE REOPENED SAFELY.
YOURS IN NEW MEXICO IS THE ONE
THAT HASN’T BEEN ALLOWED.
TO SAY WE HOPE THAT CHANGES VERY
SOON.
WE HAVE REACHED OUT FOR AN
ANSWER.
WE WILL LET YOU KNOW IF WE GET